[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in a series of dawn raids the military
moved in
civilian leader aung san tsuchi was
arrested
a state of emergency was declared
protests erupted across the country
we followed one protester two weeks into
the coup this was his message back then
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
the protesters were soon met with tear
gas water cannon and worse
calls for international intervention
went unanswered
three months on this was the new reality
shops were shut
banks were closed an economy in free
fall a society living in fear
living styles abruptly changed for us
sleeping at night is full of fear and
just going out isn't totally safe
anymore you are in constant worry if the
police or army might suddenly arrest you
thousands sought refuge in neighbouring
countries we spoke to one woman who fled
yangon to start over in thailand
when you're on the list they will track
you down and if they don't find you they
will arrest your parents your children
your grandparents whoever they get in
hands just to get even
many others left their city lives to
join rebel forces in the jungle
doctors teachers students even beauty
queens
so many people that die
that i feel really sad
i can't stay like this anymore
so i decide to come
every day we have a training we are
training for
girl that was there the sixth morning we
have to do exercise and then we have to
make it
for the teamwork
and then how to hold again and how to
shoot again
across the country violence has only
intensified as the military battles
armed ethnic groups and volunteer
people's defence force units we spoke to
soldiers who risked their lives to
defect
it's for very faithful cm soldiers k
innocent protester
this is known for the professional and
honorable soldiers
i couldn't accept
their action on the military any longer
the military seized power claiming
widespread voter fraud in november 2020
elections it promised to hold free and
fair elections within two years it now
says it will hold a vote in august 2023
one year on since the coup some 1500
people have been killed
thousands more have been arrested aung
san tsuchi faces at least six years in
prison the threat of a full-blown civil
conflict edges closer but for now the
military maintains its grip on power
[Music]